la visita Brasil del ministro de
exteriores rusos ergui labrov se produce
en un momento de fuerte tensiones entre
Brasil y Estados Unidos por la postura
del presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva sobre el conflicto entre Rusia y
Ucrania es sabido que
lulaculpa de alguna forma occidente a la
propia Ucrania por esta guerra siempre
suele decir que dos no se pelean si uno
no quiere pero hay hora hay otros
elementos acaba de volver de China vemos
que quiere relanzar la figura de y el
papel de su país a nivel internacional
pero se mueve en un territorio muy
complicado donde es difícil agradar a
todos parecería que Brasil estaría
alejándose de su tradicional postura
neutral en el momento en que Lula
sugiere que el dólar sea sustituido por
otra moneda en las transacciones
comerciales internacionales también
sabemos que Brasil depende mucho de los
fertilizantes de Rusia para
su sector fundamental de la economía que
es el agronegocio entonces no es fácil
condenar la posición de Rusia a pesar de
que Lula ha dicho en más de una ocasión
que se opone a que el país de Vladimir
Putin se quede con los territorios
ocupados entonces vemos a un Brasil que
intenta recobrar protagonismo tras
cuatro años de ostracismo y de perfil
bajo de la era bolsonaro pero el
escenario no es fácil y la pregunta es
si Lula contribuirá a crear un
multipolarismo para evitar aquella
división tradicional entre Estados
Unidos y